all right the media they're foaming at
the mouth awaiting details to leak from
James commis upcoming tell-all book just
take a look at how CNN covered one of
the quote bombshells earlier today you
cannot make this stuff up some explosive
new excerpts from the former FBI
director james comey 'he's new book
crystallizer you know you've just read
the story in new york post it's got some
truly salacious details of a
conversation that the president
supposedly had with kobe right so we
knew that there was gonna be some
bombshells in here this certainly is a
big one I want to read just a few of the
quotes from the New York Post as
obtained the Comey memoir as obtained by
the New York Post this is regarding
Comey writing about Trump he brought up
what he called the golden showers thing
adding that it bothered him if there was
quote even a 1% chance and quote his
wife Melania thought it was true then it
goes on he just rolled on unprompted
explaining why it couldn't possibly be
true ending by saying he was thinking of
asking me to investigate the allegations
to prove it was a lie I said it was up
to him
that's CNN bombshell that's commis
bombshell
this is ridiculous joining us now with
reaction former deputy assistant the
president Trump Fox News national
security strategist dr. Sebastian Gorka
former Utah congressman Fox News
contributor jason Chaffetz dr. korkor
I'll start with ok if lies were paid for
by Hill we didn't know probably at the
time you're but if lies were told about
you wouldn't you and you're talking to
the FBI director and it's a fake phony
dossier to manipulate the minds of the
American people and it's full of lies
that you know aren't true what do you
want to say the guy can you find out
that's not true
isn't that the natural reaction short
all that we know for sure is James Comey
is a liar and CNN are a bunch of
perverts that's all you need that's the
that's the bombshell the president want
he knew it wasn't true because
we know it's true because it was a
Russian information operation paid for
by Hillary and he wants to have his
director of the fbi's proved to the
world not just his wife as you would
want that it isn't true
the these guys are so disconnected from
reality and so disconnected from the
American people it's not surprising that
nobody watches them and they have to pay
for airports to put their shows off all
right
good point Touche but but there's a
bigger issue here congressman and the
bigger issue and all this is liberals
hated James Comey they were the Harry
Reid wanted him out said he shouldn't be
the director of the FBI now you see this
guy I I think he has legal issues tell
me if I'm wrong leaking privileged
information leaking him to somebody for
the purpose of getting a special counsel
appointed did he did he lie to Trump in
January 2017 when he said the dossier
was salacious and I'm verified or when
they were presenting it to a FISA Court
judge in a FISA application to spy on an
American as the as the Grassley gram
memo says as the bulk of information as
Andrew Weissman said no dossier no FISA
warrant request or application so when
did he lie in October 2016 or January
2017 no I think director Comey has a
series of serious legal challenges he
testified under oath in that question by
by John Radcliffe about when did he make
the decision of whether or not she was
guilty or not guilty or was she gonna be
charged I should say and it clearly was
writing this out multiple times before
you have senator Grassley ask him
directly was he party to releasing
information surreptitiously he was
definitive in saying no only the Lord
later that that was never lies there's a
whole series of things to if I went to
Congress and lie before Congress when we
talk you should but do you remember we
asked the FBI
we asked director Comey directly myself
and Bob Goodlatte the chairman of the
Judiciary Committee did Hillary Clinton
lie under oath
he said well they never had a referral
so we sent him a referral guess what
they never got back to us never
considered any of that material when
they lied under oath and Hillary Clinton
violate the law congressman 18 USC 793
miss Hanson classified top secret did
Hillary Clinton do you think she
obstructed justice when she deleted
subpoenaed emails yes acid-washed her
hard drive beat up her devices is that
acquiring obstruction of justice sir yes
absolutely I was the fifth at the FBI
director told us that she did and and
dr. Gork oh did he rigged the
investigation by exonerating her and
writing out the exoneration before the
investigation not only did he rigged the
investigation in her favor because he
thought she would be the next president
not only did she obstruct that justice
by the bleach bitten destroying the
evidence guess what the FBI agents did
the same thing when they didn't put her
under oath and destroyed the hard drives
and that goes back to Comey unbelievable
this is where we are and are we ever
gonna get the congressman the Inspector
General report investigating all this
that should prove all of this about two
weeks out as best I can tell and I think
that will be the true bombshell that's
the thing we actually should be paying
attention to as a country I agree
interesting timing it's going to be
after commis book tour after commis
release of the book and interviews it'll
be interesting